[Music]
to the ancient romans the planet mars
was symbolic of blood
and war
but to many people today
the red planet may hold the key
for a bright new future for humanity
[Music]
the story of mars began about 4.5
billion years ago when gas and dust
swirl together to form the fourth planet
from the sun
mars is the second smallest planet in
the solar system with a diameter just
shy of the width of africa
in fact its entire surface area is
similar to that of all of earth's
continents combined
much like its terrestrial cousin mars is
dense and has a rocky composition
at the center of the planet is a core
made of iron nickel and sulfur which may
have created a protective magnetic field
during mars earlier years
enveloping the core is a rocky mantle
made of silicate minerals
and a crust rich in iron
these iron minerals react with the trace
amounts of oxygen in mars's atmosphere
and rusts
giving the planet its signature reddish
hue
while its bloodlike appearance inspired
the ancient romans to name mars after
their god of war
the planet's rusty color could be
considered symbolic of the planet's
prime days long past
[Music]
today mars is dry desolate and cold with
temperatures dropping as low as negative
225 degrees fahrenheit
but billions of years ago the planet was
much warmer more geologically active and
had a watery surface
lake beds and river valleys snake along
the face of mars indicating that liquid
water was for a time present
[Music]
volcanoes such as olympus mons the
largest volcano in the solar system at
three times the height of mount everest
once erupted lava
but by about 50 million years ago soon
after earth's dinosaurs died out mars
volcanoes also went extinct
water on the red planet still exists
today but mostly in the form of polar
ice caps
because of factors such as the presence
of water some scientists believe life
may have existed on the red planet and
may exist again
since the 1960s space programs from
around the world have launched missions
to mars in attempts to understand the
planet's past present and potential for
sustaining life
life on another planet
may well be out of reach for the near
future
but if any planet can give us hope
mars may hold the key to the survival of
humanity
[Music]
[Music]
you